it's unclear but there's no doubt that
brains of children versus teenagers
versus adults are different and I think
it's important for us to remember that
your brain is truly a work in progress
and that when you're a child your
ability to learn things is quite
remarkable and it's there is a
plasticity to your brain so that if you
want to learn to speak Italian you will
learn to speak Italian at 10:00 or 11:00
with as natural and accent to someone
who's grown up in Rome and yet if you
learn to speak Italian after the age of
13 and 14 you can learn the vocabulary
and you can certainly learn the grammar
but your accent won't be nearly as
natural especially even if you learn it
at 40 or 50 where it becomes very trying
for your brain to learn that new
language so essentially what happens is
that at 13 your brain essentially says
we have to become more efficient it's
very bushy out there you know every
everything there's so many little roads
and making little connections between
different parts of your brain that
aren't being used the brain Sencha Lee
says if you haven't used it we're going
to lose it so if you haven't used that
little country road let's say the secure
this little route to learn to play golf
or to learn to speak Italian we're going
to eliminate that and we're going to
create structured super highways in our
brain for learning so in eighth and
ninth grade our subject matter becomes
much more comprehensive we are able to
learn so much more that doesn't mean as
I said that you can't learn Italian or
play golf but it becomes much more of an
intellectual or cognitive experience so
if you stopped playing golf for six
months the next time you go out on the
course you have to remember what is it
that I'm supposed to do how am I
supposed to hold the club what am I
supposed to do when I swing through
verses if you learned early in life and
you stopped you just have an actual
swing you get back on the course and if
we look at great Olympic athletes they
all learned to do their sports very
early on four five six seven certainly
before 13 so at 13 your brain is
becoming more efficient and that
efficiency
really and renovation takes until you're
25 years old and it's during that time
of restructuring and renovation that
serious psychiatric illness occurs so
whether it is the first bouts of
depression at 13 and 14 or schizophrenia
at 18 or 19 or manic depressive illness
or true adult bipolar disorder at 19 or
20 all those things occur when the brain
is under this this reconstruction or
this renovation so quite clearly the
effects of medication on a child versus
an hour lesson versus adult are very
different and very often children will
need lower doses children will be more
sensitive to the medicine then than a
teenager or an adult